हेलो फ्रेंड्स वेलकम तू अवर युटुब चैनल
डिफ्लोरेंस अकादमी मेरा नाम है आयुष पाठक
और आज हम लोग देखने वाले हैं नेटवर्क
सिक्योरिटी का दें 9 ऑलरेडी आपको पता है
की डेट तक सारे लेक्चर अपलोड हो चुके हैं
और मैं जो भी टास्क थे जो भी चीज से तास
मेरा मतलब यानी की शेयरिंग टास्क आज मेरा
मतलब है जितने भी लेफ्ट हो रहे थे मुझे
लगता है वो सब आपने साथ में किया होंगे
जितने भी चीज मैंने कहीं थी की मैं जो कर
रहा हूं साथ तप करते चलिए प्रैक्टिस करते
चलिए अपने नोट्स बनाते चलिए उम्मीद करता
हूं मैं अपने वो किया होगा ठीक है अगर आप
नोट सही बना रहे हैं तो एटलिस्ट प्रैक्टिस
तो करते चलिए और जो की प्वाइंट्स हैं उनको
नोट करते रहिए अगर आप डिटेल में नहीं बना
रहे हैं तो देखो दिक्कत नहीं है ठीक है
लेकिन काम इतना जो है चला राहत है जो
रिवाइज करना चाहे बात भी और जल्दी से
रिवाइज कर पे उसके ठीक है चलिए तो उम्मीद
करता हूं डेट तक आपने पूरा कर लिया होगा
सब कुछ समझ लिया होगा कोई दिक्कत आपको
नहीं होगी दिक्कत तो आप टेलीग्राम पूछ
सकते हैं हमारा लिंक तो इंडिया पर फॉलो कर
सकते हैं इसमें जो भी पोस्ट आएंगे तो आप
अपना कर सकते हैं क्या आपको सीखने मिला
क्या आप की रिटायरमेंट है आपको अगर और कुछ
डिमांड है आपकी कोई जेनुइन डिमांड तो वो
आप यहां पे बोल सकते हैं ठीक है तो उसे हम
लोग पुरी करनी है कोशिश करेंगे ऑलरेडी
हमारा एंड्राइड एप्लीकेशन भी लॉन्च हो गया
है उसका भी डाउनलोड कर दीजिए उसे पे अपना
रिव्यू दीजिए ठीक है जैसा आपको जो भी
इंटरफेस ग रहा है जो भी दिक्कत है बताइए
जो भी अगर कोई सही कर दी जाएगी ठीक है तो
उसको इस वाले जरूर कर लीजिएगा उसके जो भी
लेटेस्ट अपडेट होंगे जितने भी लेटेस्ट ऑफर
होंगे जो भी नए-नए क्वेश्चन होंगे उनके
बड़े में आपको मिल जाएगा ठीक है चलिए
स्टार्ट करते हैं आगे का लेक्चर आज क्लोज
कर देता हूं पहले यहां पे ट्राई एक्ट में
इन्होंने कहा जाता है नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी
वाले यहां पर मोडल में ठीक है यहां पर
तीन-चार रूम में ऑलरेडी कर लिए एडवांस
भारत चैनल हम लोग कर रहे थे ठीक है देखिए
कहां तक हमने किया था वो एक बार मैं आपको
याद दिल डन पहले हमने क्या शिखा सबसे पहले
हमने पहले तो नेटवर्क के बेसिक समझे ठीक
है इसके बाद हमने क्या किया एक नेटवर्क
में जब घुसते हैं ठीक है
जब आप एक नेटवर्क के अंदर आपको पहले सारे
पोस्ट 25 करना पड़ेगा ना कितने होस्ट है
उसमें वो हमने शिखा ठीक है आईडेंटिफाई हो
टाइप होस्ट यानी कौन से लाइव है इसके बाद
हमने समझा की कैसे पट करेंगे
इसके बड़े में समझा कुछ एडवांस भारत के
मेथड के लिए ताकि अगर आपका वॉल ब्लॉक कर
रहा है या ऐसे कोई दिक्कत ए रही है तो
उसको कैसे पास करते हैं ठीक है और किस
तरीके से अलग-अलग कोर्स करेंगे और कैसे आप
अपनी कस्टमर को जेनरेट कर सकते हैं कस्टमर
तरीके से ठीक है ये सब हमने देख लिया था
अब यहां पर एक दूसरे से आता है तो फाइव से
यहां से थोड़ा सा एक अलग से और आता है ठीक
है जो खास करके मतलब फायर बाल से बचाने का
फैसला
तो बता दिया था ठीक है ऑलरेडी लेकिन मुझे
लगता है आपको प्रैक्टिकल दिखाई जरूर है
जितना हो पाएगा ठीक है मैं इसको रिपीट कर
रहा हूं वापस से ये वाले को मुझे ऐसा लगा
थोड़ा और प्रैक्टिकल की जरूर है इसमें फिर
हम लोग आगे बढ़ेंगे ठीक है चलिए
स्टार्ट करते हैं यह वाला सलवार
की मां लीजिए आपका यहां पर एक मशीन है ठीक
है ये आपकी जो है टारगेट मशीन है आपको
इसमें भारत स्कैन करना है तो एक तरीका है
क्या सिंपल कोई भी टेक्निक लगाइए ठीक है
कोई फोर्स नहीं तो वो तो ठीक है अपनी जगह
पर है लेकिन अब ना जो एड्रेस फाइल कर
दीजिए पर एग्जांपल खाने का मतलब क्या जैसे
मैं यहां पे नोटपैड समझता हूं आपको देखिए
आप क्या है आप है अब ठीक है और आपने सेंड
अपने सेंड किया क्या एक लेटर ठीक है
आप अब है और आपने एक लेटर भेजो है डीसी को
लेकिन अपने डीसी को भेजते रहो लेटर दिया
है आप मुझे लेटर भेजो है उसमें क्या लिखा
है उसमें स्टैंडर्ड का एड्रेस क्या दाल
दिया है आपने एक्स ए ठीक है क्या हो रहा
है अब ने एक लेटर भेजो ठीक है डीसी को ठीक
है
और सेंटर एड्रेस लेटर में क्या लिख दिया
एक्स ए ठीक है तो अब जब डीसी इस लेटर को
पड़ेगा वो कैसे चलेगा किसने भेजो है एक्स
वे नहीं भेजो है अब डीसी
रिस्पांस लेटर में क्या होने वाला है तो
इसी के रिस्पांस लेटर तो डीसी ही होगा ठीक
है यहां पर क्या था सेंटर ये था और
डेस्टिनेशन क्या था
जिसने उसने सेंडर को क्या कर दिया
सॉरी
ठीक है सेंडर को उसने क्या लिख दिया एक्सी
और डेस्टिनेशन डीसी तो बाइक मतलब ऐसे तो
जेनुइनली यहां पर सेंटर की जगह अब होना
चाहिए था ठीक है अब लेटर भेज रहा है डीसी
को ठीक है उसको लिखना चाहिए तो क्या यहां
पे अब ठीक है हम भेज रहे हैं और कहां
पूछना चाहिए डीसी पे लेकिन उसने क्या लिख
दिया एक्सी भेज रहा है और आप उसे डीसी पे
और जो डीसी को जनरेटर मिला है तो उसमें
क्या लिखा है उसने लिखा की देख तो हम रहे
हैं और पहुंचाना कहां चाहिए
सूचना का चाहिए एक्सी पे ठीक है यह मतलब
क्या अब ने डीसी को लेटर भेजो ठीक है अपनी
जगह से के नाम दे दिया की फी भेज रहा है
आपको ये लेटर एड्रेस ही रहेगा तो डीसी को
मिल गया अब डीसी को जब मिला है डीसी ने
सोचा एक्सी ने भेजो था तो डीसी रेस्पॉन्ड
किसको करेगा ये रिस्पांस करेगा एक्सी को
ठीक है ये तीनों कॉन्सेप्ट था से तरीके से
पोर्ट करेंगे होता है हमने क्या किया हमने
रिक्वेस्ट भेजो है ठीक है हमने यहां पर
डायमंड खोलना हूं मैं हमने मशीन को
रिक्वेस्ट भेजो लेकिन सोर्स आईपीओ थी हमने
क्या किया की दूसरी वाली आईपी है तो हमारे
अपील की दूसरी ठीक है तो उसको क्या लगेगा
की दूसरा सिस्टम स्कैन कर रहा है दूसरा
सिस्टम दे रहा है जब वो रिस्पांस इशू
करेगा तो फिर रिस्पांस तो दूसरे सिस्टम के
लिए ही शुरू करेगा ना उसको पता ही नहीं की
हमने भेजी थी उसको ग रहा है दूसरे सिस्टम
में भेजो था तो ये दिक्कत हो जाति है की
आपने भेज तो ये रिक्वेस्ट है रिस्पांस
आपको कैसे मिलेगा तो उसके लिए रिस्पांस
आपको कभी नहीं मिलेगा ऐसे डायरेक्टली आपको
सिस्टम पे लेकिन उसके लिए आपको अपने पूरे
नेटवर्क में स्टीफिंग करनी पड़ेगी मतलब
जितना भी जो भी ट्रैफिक है वो जो ट्रेड हो
रहा है ठीक है कोई नेटवर्क है वो कैप्सूल
करना पड़ेगा वो कैसे करते हैं वो आगे वाली
चीज है ठीक है लेकिन आपको सेट करना पड़ेगा
जब थोड़ा मुश्किल राहत है करना ठीक है जब
तक अगर वह नहीं करेंगे की आपको नेटवर्क
ट्रैफिक कोई कैप्चर करके उसको एनालाइज
करना पड़ेगा की क्या-क्या रिस्पांस ए जाए
और उसके बेस पे पोर्ट ओपन है ठीक है ये
काफी कंप्रेसर उसके लिए आता है क्योंकि
यहां पर आपका फिनिश हो जाता है ठीक है
जिसकी वजह से काफी सारे ट्रैफिक जेनरेट
होगी उसमें से करना वैसे दिक्कत होती है
ठीक है तो ये होता कारपेट एक्ट नहीं है
ठीक है चलिए समझ आया उसने वो क्या है विच
गैप यू हुई है यहां पर अपडेट आईफोन एस
देकर टेक्स्ट जाएगा स्पीड डैशिंग मशीन
दीजिए मतलब जो भी मशीन का आपको दिखाना है
विप से स्कैनिंग हो रही है वो आईपी दीजिए
ठीक है इस तरीके से आप हिफिन हिप्न टेस्ट
मैं लगा के नकली दे सकते हैं अपने नेटवर्क
के अंदर ठीक है तो ये तो चलिए ठीक है
इसमें वाली है अब हम लोग बात करेंगे ठीक
है जो उससे रिलेटेड ये है काफी काम आएगा
क्यों अगर आपके लिए ये देखिए हमने क्या इस
टाइम की आइडिया में बच्चन आगे हम स्कैनिंग
कर रहे हैं ठीक है या हम ही स्कैन कर रहे
हैं उससे बचाने तरीका क्या है आपने जब
पूरा तरीका लगाया है तो बस तो है आपने
फाइट कर लिया ठीक है लेकिन हायड करने के
बाद आपको दिक्कत ये हो गई की भाई आपके पास
मिलेगा
ठीक है अभी हमारे टारगेट ब्लॉक ही कर रहा
है रिक्वेस्ट
ये है की उससे बच्चे कैसे नोटिस में रहा
है की हम ही कर रहे हैं ठीक है हमें लॉक्स
में नहीं आना है दूसरी तरीका अब देखिए
एग्जांपल अगर इसे आपने मतलब कभी भी अपने
रियल लाइफ में बेचे देखा होगा ठीक है जैसे
मां लीजिए स्कूल यूनिवर्सिटी कॉलेज में
बिल्कुल लाइव रहती है अगर ठीक है ये बहुत
ही रिलेटेबल एग्जांपल ग रहा होगा आपको तो
अगर उसमें कोई एक बच्चा का नाम आता है
सामने ठीक है की इस बच्चे ने भाई लड़ाई की
थी या एक किया था ठीक है तो उसको
रिस्ट्रिकेट सस्पेंस हो जाएगा ठीक है
लेकिन अगर वहीं पे ग्रुप का नाम आता है
ठीक है ये पुरी ग्रुप के बच्चे पूरे ग्रुप
यही होती है यूनिटी ठीक है भाई किसने किया
था कोई नाम ही नहीं रहे तो पुरी टिकट कर
पाएंगे क्या नहीं कर पाएंगे ठीक है वहां
पे कन्फ्यूजन राहत है की ये किसने था वही
जरा कॉन्सेप्ट यहां पे भी है हम क्या करते
हैं अटैक करने का किया देखिए एक दो तीन
यहां पर एग्जांपल के लिए तीन रिक्वेस्ट दी
हुई है इसने एक ही पोर्ट्स के करने को
जैसे स्कैन करना है तो तीन अलग-अलग
रिक्वेस्ट की तीन अलग-अलग आईपीएस है
जिसमें से एक उसकी ओरिजिनल वाईफाई थी और
दो उसकी नकली आई पी थी ठीक है अब वो नकली
आई पी किसी और डिवाइस की हो चाहे मत हो
उससे फर्क नहीं पड़ता ठीक है
रिक्वेस्ट मिली अब वो तीनों आईपी पे तीन
तीन रेस्पॉन्ड भेजेगा मतलब तीन रेस्पॉन्ड
भेजेगा ठीक है अब उनमें से एक तो हमारा
ओरिजिनल
मिल गया तो इससे काम ये हुआ की जो हमारे
पास तीन रिक्वेस्ट है यहां पे एग्जांपल के
लिए तीन दी गई है अपन लीजिए शॉर्ट हो गए
देखते हैं अगर आप सॉरी कुछ भेजते करने के
लिए तो उससे मालूम
है कौन सी फालतू है मतलब सिर्फ भीड़ बनाने
के लिए ठीक है ये तरीका उसे किया गया तो
चलिए ये होगा कैसे
इसको हम लोग प्रैक्टिकल समझेंगे इसलिए
मैंने इस मॉडल को वापस से रिपीट किया है
ठीक है इस वाले को लेकिन मुझे लगा इसको
आपको थोड़ा अच्छे से समझने की थोड़ी जरूर
है ठीक है तो पहले मैं फ्रेश कर लेट हूं
यहां पर वर्षा के बड़े में पता होगा
नेटवर्क ट्रैफिक कब से करनाल है तो फिलहाल
हम सिर्फ कैट मतलब कैप्चर कर पाएंगे अपने
डिवाइस पर ट्रैफिक ठीक है इसको यहां पर
फिलहाल के लिए चलिए मैं क्या करूंगा मैं
यहां पर अपना ओपन कर लेट हूं यहां पर
स्टूडेंट हो गई ठीक है
मैं क्या करूंगा इस कमांड कॉपी कर लेते
हैं हम लोग
पूरा फिलहाल के लिए अब देखिए मैं यहां पर
से कॉपी कर रहा हूं टेस्ट कर रहा हूं अब
मशीन की जगह मैं यहां पर अपने राउटर थी
पेस्ट कर दूंगा ठीक है
ना टाइम वेस्ट हो जाएगा ठीक है जैसा
ट्रैफिक यहां पर जेनरेट होगा
देखिए हमने क्या कहा है इसको की 10 10
चालू कर दो ठीक है तो हमें आंसर मिल जाएगा
ये दो हाइड्रोजन
देते हैं ठीक है अब ट्रैफिक देखते हैं
क्या यहां पर हमारा जो लेजिटीमेट फोर्स
क्या है ना वो कहां से हो रहा है ये देखिए
यहां पर तीन टोटल तीन से स्टार्ट होता है
ध्यान रखिए और ये तीनों कहां से भेजें गए
हैं इसका स्कोर देखिए सोर्स मतलब किसने
भेजो है ठीक है
चलिए देखिए
तीन रिक्वेस्ट कहां कहां से हुई है सोर्स
मतलब कहां से भेजो गया है एक तो एड्रेस
है ठीक है दूसरा ये दो देखिए
10.10.2 से क्या भेजो गया है राउटर पे
क्या भेजो गया है सिम पैकेट पोर्ट नंबर 80
पे और यही दो एड्रेस हमने जो है यहां पर
दिए थे ये देखिए ये जो एड्रेस हमने यहां
पर दिए थे तो ये जबकि कमल के बाद ये मेरा
नेटवर्क ही नहीं है
उसका जो प्रशिक्षण कर सकते हैं 192.1 है
ठीक है ना की 10.8 में कुछ भी दे सकता हूं
एक और एड करता हूं यहां पे
ठीक है लेकिन इससे क्या हुआ फिर बाढ़ गई
ठीक है इससे भीड़ बाढ़ गई और हमारा जो
ट्रैफिक
है और सारे एपिडेरमोट दे रहे हैं ठीक है
और एक आपका यूनिक दिखे रहा है तो देखिए
फ्रेंड ए जाएगा तो वैसे करके नहीं करनी है
जो भी आईपीएल में दिन है वो सिमिलर दिखने
चाहिए लाइव होस्ट करेंगे और अच्छा रहेगा
खाने का मतलब क्या आप स्कैनिंग कर लीजिए
पहले ठीक है मेरा कोई दूसरा कर लीजिए ठीक
है मैं करता हूं यहां पर
यहां से लेक आप अपना जो भी आपका नेट मास्क
है पूरा आपका जो नेटवर्क है उसको स्कैन कर
लीजिए ठीक है यहां पर मैं स्क्रीन चालू कर
देता हूं
और यहां पे अपने जो कमांड है उसको इस
तरीके से मॉडिफाई कर दीजिए जो भी आपका
आईपी एड्रेस रेंज है
चलिए तो काफी
है
ठीक है और हमें दोस्तों मिलते हैं
मिलते हैं
यहां पर ठीक है
ना चालू करते हैं
स्टार्ट करते हैं वापस से
स्टार्ट
वैसा कोई गलती नहीं करनी आपको ठीक है
लेकिन इस टाइप का अगर आप से कितना करेंगे
तब जो लाइव हो तो ऑलरेडी है जो की रैचेबल
भी हो सिस्टम से तो वहां पे देकर करना
मुश्किल हो जाएगा अगर आप रेडलाइन उसे
करेंगे तो आपने चेक करना थोड़ा सा समझ में
ए जाएगा अगर वो सारे एपी को एक लॉक में
लेक उसको स्कैनिंग शुरू करते हैं की भाई
कौन कौन सा आईपी अवेलेबल है की नहीं है
ठीक है ऐसी रेंडम दे दिया गया है तो पकड़े
जाएंगे ठीक है तो वो इंपॉर्टेंट चीज है तो
ध्यान रखना ठीक है इस तरीके से छोटे-छोटे
चीजों को आपको ध्यान रखना है चलिए समझ में
ए गया प्रैक्टिकल इसका इसलिए मुझे लगा था
इसका प्रैक्टिकल के साथ थोड़ा जरूरी है
मैंने आपको दिखा दिया
क्या होता है ठीक है एक नेटवर्क में कोई
भी मतलब आपका सुरक्षा इंडियन आर्मी हमारे
लिए ठीक है यदि कोई भी जो थ्रेड या कोई भी
प्रॉब्लम है कोई मालिश से रिक्वेस्ट करो
रुकती है ठीक है ना ये कहां है सर क्या है
उसको चेक करना है जो मैंने आपसे कहा था अब
कभी एम क्या चल रहा है अभी आपका जो अभी
हमने जो सखी है उसका कोई पास करना मतलब हम
डिटेक्टर ना हो पे हम विचारक ट्रैफिक के
बीच में घुसेंगे की देखिए गुस्सा वाला
उठने में कोई नहीं घुस पाएगा इस तरीके से
लेकिन अगर आप अपने ट्रैफिक के बीच में
घुसेंगे तो आप नहीं समझ पाएगा की आप कौन
से ट्रेन में से एलईडी में हैकर कौन सा है
इसमें ठीक है चलिए
बात कर लेते हैं यहां पर 5 मिनट पैकेट की
बहुत बढ़िया फीचर प्रोवाइड करता है ठीक है
जिसमें हम जो पैकेट है उसको छोटे-छोटे
पार्ट में डिवाइड करके भेज सकते हैं ताकि
कहते हैं उतना नहीं होता है लेकिन होते
हैं जो आपके मतलब छोटे पैकेट से बड़े
पैकेट को अलग कर देंगे ठीक है यहां पर
मेंशन ज्यादा चीज जो है बाईपास करने के
लिए
मतलब लगाएंगे ठीक है तो वो क्या करेगा 16
मेडिटेशन सॉरी 8/7 में डिवाइड कर देगा ठीक
है अगर आप डबल एफ लगाते हैं तो लाइफ में
डबल एफ तो वो 16 / 2 में मैंने 8 की
मल्टीपल में करना है आपको ठीक है
वेबसाइट कर सकते हैं इसका 33 दिखता हूं
डायरेक्टली देखिए हम लोग यहां पर ओपन कर
लेते हैं
ठीक है
80 ठीक है अब मैं यहां पर फिलहाल एफ लिखना
हूं ठीक है पहले आपको नॉर्मल दिखता हूं
वैसे ही ठीक है
वापस से
चलिए व्हाट्सएप में वापस ओपन कर लेट हूं
ताकि थोड़ा समझ में आया आपको अच्छे से
लगा दिया मैंने
स्टार्ट करते हैं
यानी कंप्लीट हो गया ठीक है देखिए नॉर्मल
सब कुछ था आपको कहानी दिखे रहा होगा ठीक
है
ठीक है
इससे क्या होगा की जो फ्रेगमेंटेशन
है तो ऐसे में क्या हो सकता है आप बता
सकता है लेकिन पॉलीटिकल ना हो लेकिन पहले
आपको काफी मिल जाता था ये देखिए
डाटा एडवाइस ठीक है चलिए
ऑप्शन इस बीइंग यूज्ड हो में
आईपीएस बिल यू गेट ठीक है आईफोन एफ एफ
मतलब क्या 8 और 816 के पार्ट में डिवाइड
करेगा मतलब एक जगह 16 होगा टोटल साइज क्या
है 64 तो 64 / 16 क्या आएगा फोर आएगा ठीक
है आंसर क्या होना चाहिए देखिए अब आपको
समझना के लिए था नहीं
प्रैक्टिकल प्रोग्रामिंग किया ट्राई
कीजिएगा तो आपको यहां पर मुझे और डिटेल
थोड़ी आएगी ठीक है ना इधर तो हम यहां पर
से 2 उसे करने समझना है और कॉन्सेप्ट कैसे
काम कर रहा है वो समझना है की ऐसी ऐसी
छोटी-छोटी टेक्निक होती है मतलब ये कितना
इंटरेस्टिंग चीज है की आप एक चीज करने का
मतलब है की इतनी तरीके से हम कर सकते हैं
जितना आप सोच सकते हैं की दूसरे डिवाइस के
नाम पे कर लो या फिर क्या नाम है
छोटे-छोटे पार्ट में कर लो एक्स्ट्रा चीज
एड करके कर लो इतने ए रहा है ठीक है
चलिए
आइडियल या फिर जॉम्बीज कैन ये भी इस से
रिलेटेड या का सकते हैं उसे जैसा ही काम
करता है ठीक है काम मतलब की ये हमारा जो
है फाइनल वही है ठीक है एंटीवायरस के नजर
में बताओ भाई ठीक है इतिहास की नजर में
राहत है एंटीवायरस सॉरी मैंने बताया
आइडिया बताओ ठीक है अब यहां पर आइडियल गैस
जॉम्बीज के अंदर क्या होता है यहां पे
आपको एक ऐसा
लेटर बहुत ही रेयर है ठीक है अब मैं ये
फिर भी क्यों बता रहा हूं मेरी इसलिए बता
रहा हूं क्योंकि ये आपको समझना जरूरी है
की ऐसा भी हो सकता है मतलब थोड़ा आपको
बॉक्स सोचना सीखना जरूरी है ठीक है और
आपको इन्हीं हम सभी को जरूरी है ठीक है
लेकिन मैं आपको बेसिक परमिशन चले जा रहे
हैं इसको कुछ भी जरूरी होता है ठीक है
चलिए इसमें कैसा कॉन्सेप्ट बढ़िया है ठीक
है आपको दिखता हूं ये देखिए डायग्राम सब
कुछ हो जाएगा अच्छे से ये चीज इसमें क्या
करते हैं जैसे कोई भी मां लीजिए मैं आपको
पहले एक सिंपल सा सिंपल कोशिश करूंगा यहां
पे लिखा हुआ है की देखिए आईपी आईडी ठीक है
यहां पर आईपी एड्रेस क्या होती है आपकी
पैकेट तरीके से एक नंबर टाइप का होता है
ठीक है यहां पर आपके डायग्राम में भी शायद
होगा
[संगीत]
जो भी नेक्स्ट नेक्स्ट पैकेट भेजता राहत
है मुझे टेक्स्ट होता है ठीक है
तो आपको यहां पे क्या करना है टेक्निकल
करना है की इसमें लीजिए आपका टेकरी आईपी
है ठीक है मतलब आप जी स्कैन करने वाले हैं
ये आपका टारगेट है मशीन यानी इसका ही आपको
स्कैन करना है ठीक है और ये जोंबी आईपी
क्या है जोंबी आईपी मतलब एक ऐसा सिस्टम
आपको चाहिए अब उसको चाहे आइडियल सिस्टम
कहिए चाहे आपको एक ऐसा सिस्टम चाहिए जो
कुछ भी नेटवर्क कनेक्शन नहीं कर रहा हो
मतलब वो अभी कोई रिक्वेस्ट नहीं कर रहा है
वो साथ में बैठा है ना कोई रिस्पांस कर
रहा है ना कोई रिक्वेस्ट कर रहा है बहुत
रेयर है इसलिए मैंने आपसे कहा की आप सिर्फ
उसके लिए लेकिन आपको एकदम ऐसा एकदम आइटम
सिस्टम चाहिए एकदम शांत बैठा है कुछ नहीं
कर रहा है ठीक है हम उसके थ्रू स्कैनिंग
करवाने वाले हैं अब कैसे करेंगे समझिए इस
चीज को देखिए
आपने अपने जॉन भी आईपी को क्या भेजो है एक
सीन एक भेजो है ध्यान से समझिएगा वो जरूर
समझिएगा बोलना हूं इस चीज को आपने
पैकेट भेजो है अब आपने
आएगा
ठीक है क्यों अगर आप
गलती से हो गया कहां से ए रहा है ठीक है
नोट कर लिया
आई थी
एक्स ठीक है अब आपने क्या किया अब आप यहां
पर अपने मशीन को ट्रिगर करने वाली है
जिसपे आपको जिसकी करनी है मां लीजिए आपको
पोर्ट्स के अंदर करना है आपने क्या किया
आपने कॉन्सेप्ट लगाया अगेन ठीक है आपने
क्या किया आपने कोर्स स्कैन की रिक्वेस्ट
भेजी है यहां पर मशीन ठीक है और सोर्स
क्या दाल दिया जोंबी आईपी मतलब आपने बोला
की भाई मैंने नहीं इसलिए भेजी है ठीक है
तो रिस्पांस स्ट्रेट जेनरेट होगा अब जैसे
इसके लिए जेनरेट होगा आपने रिक्वेस्ट भेजी
स्कूल वाली रिस्पांसिबिलिटी हुआ यहां पर
कैसे किया था यहां पर कैसे किया था की
आपका जो पोर्ट था वो क्लोज था तो रिस्पांस
होगा रिसेट होगा और वहीं अगर आपका फोटो
ओपन होता है रिस्पांसिबिलिटी होता है अब
दोनों में डिफरेंस कैसे मालूम चलेगा देखिए
अगर यहां पर रिसेट जेनरेट हो रहा है रिसेट
ठीक है तो रिसेट के बाद ये कोई रिप्लाई
नहीं करेगा तो हम भी ठीक है तो रिप्लाई
नहीं करेगा ठीक है लेकिन अगर आपका यहां पर
ओपन है ठीक है तो ये क्या हो जाएगा तब
आपका ये सिस्टम क्या भेजेगा ये फिर भेजेगा
क्योंकि इसमें
रिक्वेस्ट नहीं किया था ना तो आपने उसको
कहा की इसने रिक्वेस्ट किया था पर इसने
खुद तो किया नहीं था तो अगर नहीं है की
रिजल्ट भेज देगा ठीक है अब इंपॉर्टेंट चीज
है अगर पोर्ट क्लोज था जांबिया इतनी
रिस्पांस नहीं दिया अगर पोर्ट ओपन था
जोंबी आई थिंक रिस्पांस दिया ठीक है हर एक
आगे वाले पैकेट में आई दी एक-एक बढ़नी
जाति है ठीक है हर एक नेक्स्ट टेक्निकल
आईपीएल की बढ़नी जाति है अभी क्या हुआ
क्लोज पोर्ट वाले में तो इसमें कोई
रिस्पांस नहीं किया ठीक है इसके लिए कोई
रिपोर्ट नहीं किया तो इसकी ईडी आई थी अभी
कहां पे रुकती हुई है x3 ऊटी हुई है लेकिन
अगर पोर्ट क्लोज था सॉरी पोर्ट अगर ओपन था
ठीक है रिस्पांस आया था इतनी रिसेट भेजो
तो आईटीआई कहां पर जाएगी प्लस वन हो जाएगी
चलिए तो आपके आईपीडी क्या हो जाएगी यहां
पर प्लस वन हो जाएगी मतलब क्या हुआ फिर से
समझावां जल्दी में ठीक है अगर आपका पोर्ट
जो है वो क्या है क्लोज है तो इसे आएगा
यहां इसको हम मिल जाएगा ठीक है जोंबी मशीन
की ठीक है लेकिन अगर आपका रिस्पांस यहां
पर जांबिका या सीन का आता है तो रिसेट
जाएगा तो आईपैड क्या हो चुकी है आईपैड
प्लस वन हो चुकी है कौन से कैसे में
वापस से जोंबी को अधिक रिक्वेस्ट भेजिएगा
कैसे रिक्वेस्ट भेजेगा वापस ऐसी रिक्वेस्ट
भेजेगा ताकि अगर उसका आईपीडी देख सके अब
क्या है ठीक है अब जो उसको आईपी मिलेगा
ठीक है दोबारा वो अगला पैकेट है तो प्लस
वन तो फिर से होगा इसमें अगेन प्लस वन हो
जाएगा इसमें क्या होगा
ठीक है इसमें अगेंस्ट मिलेगा तो सबसे पहले
मैं क्या करेगा सबसे पहले तो वो प्लस वन
को यहां पर देखिएगा ये देखिएगा ठीक है अब
देखिए आपका फोटो ओपन था इसीलिए ये वाला
प्रश्न हुआ था और ये प्लस वन तो होगा ही
होगा क्योंकि आपको रिस्पांस मिल रहा है तो
कल मिला के कन्फ्यूजन नहीं निकलेगा की जो
एक्स उसने स्टार्टिंग में नोट किया था वो
और अभी जो एड्रेस मिला है अगर उसमें दो
बार प्लस वन हुआ है इसका मतलब तू डिफरेंस
जो है वो तू का है ठीक है इसका मतलब आपका
ओपन है और आपका क्लोज होता था तो ये वाला
प्रश्न तो होता नहीं आपका सिर्फ ये वाला
प्रश्न होता है डिफरेंस वन कहा जाता है
इसका मतलब क्या हुआ अगर डिफरेंस
वन का आता है तो पोर्ट
इस ओपन ठीक है
जोंबी ने एक अभी दूसरी एक्टिविटी कर दी
नेटवर्क में उसका आईपी आईडी बादल जाएगा
और वो हमें नहीं पता कितना इंक्रीमेंट हुआ
है ठीक है तो हम कभी जिंदगी में पता नहीं
कर पाएंगे की फोटो बताएं कन्फ्यूजन चले
जाएंगे ठीक है या फिर बोल रॉक देता है ठीक
है
जो रिसेट आया था ठीक है रिसेट का
स्क्रीनशॉट दिया था नहीं दिया था ठीक है
टीचर के कैसे नहीं दिया था इसलिए प्रश्न
नहीं हुआ था अगर यहां पर मशीन आईपी में
ब्लॉक कर देता है ठीक है भेजना में देता
है तो भी आपका यहां प्लस वन नहीं होगा इस
कैसे में भी क्या लगेगा की पोर्ट आपका
क्लोज हो जाएगा की आपका ओपन हो सकता है
ठीक है सिर्फ पोर्ट ओपन जो है वो कंफर्म
रहेगा वो भीतर जब नेटवर्क के बीच में कोई
भी दिक्कत ना आए की मतलब अगर बीच में भी
कहानी और बात कर लिया उसका आईडी बन जाएगा
और हमें नहीं पता कितना बाढ़ गया तो हम
डिफरेंस से आंसर का पता नहीं कर पाएंगे
ठीक है ना इसलिए मैंने कहा ये मुश्किल
होता है क्योंकि ऐसा गंभीर कुछ ना कुछ
रेयर है ठीक है ऐसा कोई सबके नेटवर्क में
होना जो कोई इंटरेक्ट कर रहा हो वो बहुत
मुश्किल है ठीक है
उसे करना है भाई कमांड देख लेते हैं यहां
पर ठीक है
आईफोन एस आई ठीक है
दोबारा समझाऊंगा समझना जरूरी होता है ठीक
है
सवाल कर सकते हैं इसका फायदा क्या है आपको
थोड़ा डिटेल मिल जाएगा जैसे की यहां पर ये
मशीन चालू है ठीक है इन चालू है क्यों
चालू है उसके रीजन आपको मिल जाएगा ठीक है
यहां पर ये नॉर्मल स्कैन है और यहां पर ये
आईफोन रीजन लगाने के बाद आपको मिल रहा है
पोस्ट के साथ बिकॉज़ रिसीवड ए आर के
रिस्पांस इस तरीके से ये पोर्ट ओपन है ओपन
है पर क्यों ओपन है क्योंकि यहां पे सीन
है या फिर रिस्पांस मिल जाएगा तो आईफोन भी
से आपको बस में मिल रहा है तो ये चीज यहां
पर आपको एक-एक चीज सामने मिल जाएगा उसका
रीजन क्या है ठीक है क्यों आपने कोई
कन्फ्यूजन जो है ड्रा किया उसका कोई मिल
जाएगा उसके सम कर सकते हैं
आप चालू करना होगा
ठीक है
यहां पर ए जाएगी तो कॉपी कर लेते हैं
मतलब जितने भी चैनल
कॉपी करके लीजिए
आपके लिए गूगल अवेलेबल है मेरे साथ देख
सकते हैं सर यहां पर जो बेसिक मिल गए हैं
इसको भी अपडेट कर दिया जाए
चलिए मशीन टाइप मेरा वो आने वाला है तब तक
करेंगे यहां पर सर्च करेंगे मिल जाएगा
यहां पर पोस्ट आएगी उसके पीछे कमेंट कीजिए
और उम्मीद रखिए ठीक है आपकी जो भी फीडबैक
हो गया जो भी होगी उसका हम सिर्फ रिस्पांस
करेंगे ठीक है और रिस्पांस नहीं भी आता है
तो उसको हम लोग पढ़ने जरूर है ठीक है आपकी
एक वीडियो थोड़ा धीरे बोलिए
जल्दी नहीं का रहा हूं अगर अच्छा ग रहा है
रिपोर्ट कीजिए
और इससे हमारा फायदा तो है आपका भी फायदा
है जैसे पहले बढ़ेगा ऊतक आएंगे ठीक है
जिसके लिए हमारे पास ट्रेन नहीं होंगे ठीक
है चलिए
चलो गया समय कॉपी कर लेट हूं
सॉरी
कर सकते हैं
ठीक है डायग्राम
ठीक है चलिए
कैपिटल देते हैं ग्रुप कंप्लीट हो गया
हमारा यह वाला
आगे देख लेते हैं आगे क्या है
भाई आगे क्या अब आगे बढ़ते हैं
ठीक है
करेंगे
लेकिन भारत केयरिंग के एक्स्ट्रा उसके ऊपर
से किया करना है ठीक है यहां पर वो चीज है
तो बेसिकली यहां पर डिस्कशन वगैरा एन एफ
के बड़े में देखिए इस वाले में तो ज्यादा
खास करके ठीक है अब इसका भी जो समझाऊंगा
तो कॉन्सेप्ट आप कहानी भी र सकते हैं ठीक
है एन तो वो सारे फीचर्स आप देख लीजिए
लेकिन वो कॉन्सेप्ट मुझे लगेगी ठीक है
यहां पर भी वही चीज है लेकिन थोड़ा यहां
पर लेक आना चलेंगे लेकिन एक्चुअली मेरे
सिर्फ एनएफ के लिए नहीं है समझना वाला फूल
करने की जरूर पड़ती है ठीक है ये करना
पड़ता है एन में ऐसा ट्रॉली है ठीक है ना
कोई चीज तो है नहीं
ठीक है चलिए स्टार्ट करते हैं
सर्विस डिक्टेशन की ठीक है अब सर्विस
जितने
कर लिया अब सर्विस क्या बच्ची भाई सर्विस
ये बच्ची की कौन सी सर्विस रन हो रही है
खाने का मतलब 22 अगर ऐसे चिरान हो रहा है
ठीक है से का कौन सा बटन है उसमें बहुत
सारे आते हैं ठीक है वो सब यहां पे करना
राहत है यहां पर कोई टास्क पहले से चालू
करते हैं फिर बात करते हैं ठीक है चलिए तो
एनएफ ने आपको एक चीज मिलता है आईफोन s3
ठीक है इस स्वीट से आप एनएफ कर सकते हैं
की भाई सर्विस का वर्जन देखेंगे स्टार्ट
कर दो ठीक है सर्विस का वर्जन स्टार्ट कर
दो जैसे यहां पर दिखाऊंगा अभी जो यहां पर
आई दिया जाएगा तो
मैं इसके बड़े में और बता देता हूं आपको
यहां पर जीरो से लेक नाइन तक लेवल राहत है
अब हिफिन हिफिन वर्जन दास इंटेंसिटी देखिए
उसके आगे यहां पर लेवल की जगह जीरो साइन
तक लिख सकते हैं अपने तांत्रिक को बनाने
के लिए ठीक है और अगर आपको मिनिमम करना है
तब आईफोन वर्जन दास लाइट करेंगे तो वो मिल
जाएगा ठीक है अगर आप आईफोन आईफोन वर्जन
दास जो करेंगे तो मैक्सिमम रहेगा ठीक है
ना
स्कैनिंग चालू करो वर्जन स्केटिंग चालू
करो ठीक है
अब सोचिए क्यों ठीक है ऑफिस बात है अगर
आपको वरजंटेशन करना है मैंने पता था जैसे
आप कोई सर्विस तो कनेक्ट करते हैं वहां पे
कुछ विकेट लेते हैं जैसे मैंने आपको स्टडी
पे नेट कैसे दिखाए था हमने सरवर को एक
बेसिक चीज एसिडिटी कर रही थी सिंपल
कैटरिंग पे और हमें बैनर में वहां पे कब
से इनफॉरमेशन मिली थी स्पंज की कौन सी चल
रहा है ठीक है उसे तरीके से जो है काम
करता है ये ठीक है तो उसके लिए आपके लिए
कनेक्शन जरूरी तो है ना भाई टेंशन तो नहीं
पड़ेगा इसलिए इसमें लिखा हुआ है की आपका
यहां पर थ्री और से करेगा ही करेगा ठीक है
तो आप इसको कोई नॉर्मल स्क्रीन कर सकते
हैं वो अपने आप उसको फ्रेंडशिप नहीं करेगा
चलिए
वो चालू भी हो गया है कॉपी कर लेते हैं
इसको यहां पर दिया हुआ है ठीक है वर्जन
यहां पे क्षेत्र बना हुआ है सारे वर्जन
दिए हुए हैं ठीक है जरूरी नहीं है
उतना अच्छा है ऐसे डिफेंस ठीक है लेकिन
इतना ही बेकार है आपके लिए टेस्ट है ठीक
है
ना
मतलब जो प्रेजेंटेशन
कर शक्ति है
जितनी जरूर है बाकी तो गूगल तो गूगल कर
लीजिए
इसमें होती है अनीता आपको
नहीं लगती चाहिए आप पढ़ने के लिए रेडी
रहेंगे हमेशा ठीक है क्वेश्चन क्या है
यहां पर वर्जन तो नहीं है क्या ये बोल रहा
है क्या
वर्जन लाइट लगाया था तो कौन सी सर्विस
डिटेक्टर नहीं कर पाया कौन सी वाली है
यहां पर वन वन का ठीक है
आपको यहां पर सभी जंक्शन कैसे काम कर रहा
है स्कूटर अंबेडकर देते हैं अभी के लिए
आगे बढ़ते हैं
अपने सभी ट्रिक चेक करना होगा आप सर्विस
स्कैन
करना है आपको जरूरी है ठीक है अच्छा तो
आपको सर्विस देख के समझ में ए जाएगा लेकिन
ये भी एक बढ़िया तरीका है ठीक है ये आपकी
फिंगर प्रिंट और बाकी किसी भी रिस्पांस ए
रहा है उसको जो है आईडेंटिफाई करके उसको
मैच करके फिंगर प्रिंट्स से हो सकता है या
फिर एक गैस लगा सकता है क्या ये भाई ये
सिस्टम ये वाला कलर हो सकता है ठीक है
इसके लिए आप स्विच कौन करते हैं अगर आप
आईफोन लिखने हैं ठीक है जीरो लेंगे वो
ध्यान रखिएगा आपका जो है यहां पर स्कैन
काम करेगा ठीक है यहां पर स्कैन कर रहा है
यहां पर अमेरिका से इसी मशीन में चालू
करना है
ठीक है यहां पर मतलब जो है करने के लिए
यहां पर इंजेक्शन परफॉर्म ठीक है
आपको ये चीज आपको याद रखना की जरूर नहीं
है ठीक है
टूट जाएगी तो अभी के लिए समझते जाइए आगे
आप समझ जाएंगे की मैं मुफ्ती कौन सी चीज
करता हूं या आप कंफ्यूज मोस्टली उसे कर
सकते हैं लोक अट्रैक्शंस के लिए चलिए
ऑप्शन अगेंस्ट मशीन
ठीक है अभी गैस भी कर सकता है इधर आपको
लेकिन डिटेल मिलेगा ठीक है वो गैस कर रहा
है या फाइनली क्योंकि जो भी है यहां पर
लिख जाति है
कॉपी ठीक है
[संगीत]
चाहिए
फिर देखते हैं
आंसर आपको मिल जाएगा
कुछ दिक्कत है
क्या
चलिए
देखते हैं
फॉर्मेट में चाहिए
तरीके से इसलिए कहते हैं की दो तीन तरीका
ट्राई कर लो और आपको नहीं करना है तो कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है उसमें ठीक है चलिए बात
करते हैं इंजन की काफी इंपॉर्टेंट चीज है
और मैं ट्रेन टर्मिनेटर चालू कर देता हूं
पहले चलिए इंजन क्या होता है अब लोअर
स्क्रिप्ट ठीक है एक लैंग्वेज है ब्लू
लैंग्वेज के थ्रू ठीक है आप यहां पर एक
स्ट्रिप बनाते हैं ठीक है मतलब बताइए की
चीज मिल जाएगी डायरेक्टली ठीक है अब अपनी
बना सकते हैं खुद की भी पहले भी आपको
मिलती है एन मैप आपको एक इंजन को एड करता
है
ठीक है जो आपके पोस्ट करने के साथ-साथ
करके आपको बहुत सारे इनफॉरमेशन एडिशनल
इनफॉरमेशन भी हेल्प कर सकता है
यूजर शेर और में
जाके दिखता हूं
यूजर शेर
और मैप
स्क्रिप्ट मिल जाएगी देखिए
आईफोन आईफोन स्क्रिप्ट इक्वल तू डिफॉल्टर
ठीक है यह देखिए या फिर सिंपल हिफिन ऐसी
डीके आप ये का सकते हैं की जैसे की हर
यहां पर स्क्रिप्ट का एक कैटिगरी है ठीक
है जैसे आज कैटिगरी की स्क्रिप्ट है गुड
पर कैटिगरी की स्क्रिप्ट डिफॉल्ट है यहां
पे ठीक है इस तरीके से स्क्रिप्ट कैटिगरी
है ठीक है तो आप अगर आपको जैसे मां लीजिए
स्कैनिंग कर रहे हैं कोई भी टारगेट स्कैन
कर रहे हैं आप आईफोन एस सी दे देते हैं
यहां पर f1 एस सी तो उससे रिलेटेड जितनी
भी स्क्रिप्ट रहेंगे वो ऑटोमेटेकली उनको
रन कर देगा ठीक है ना इसके साथ डायरेक्टली
नहीं तो आप सिंपल यहां पर मेरे पास दिया
होगा वो भी नीचे दिया होगा आईफोन आईफोन
स्किप देख के आप इस्पेशली प्रोवाइड कर
सकते हैं की नहीं मुझे सिर्फ ये वाली
स्क्रिप्ट ही रन करनी है ठीक है आईफोन से
जितनी
डिफॉल्ट थी ठीक है वो अपने आप जो है रन हो
गई है ठीक है जो भी इनफॉरमेशन हो शक्ति है
वो मिल जा रही है चलिए अब हिफिन हिफिन
स्क्रिप्ट डीके स्पेस यहां पर
डिस्क्रिप्शन
करनी है तो वो जो स्क्रिप्ट हो जाएगी ठीक
है ना जैसे यहां पर क्या है इन्होंने एचडी
वीडियो प्रिंट किया है
चलिए देख लेते हैं
स्क्रिप्ट
क्या करता है रोबोट
एचटीटीपी रोबोट
चाहिए देख लेते हैं
ठीक है
नहीं हो सकता इसको ओपन कर देते हैं यहां
पर दिया हुआ होगा एंट्रीज
मतलब
एचटीटीपी
वर्ल्ड आगे पूरा यही चीज
अमेरिका से शॉर्ट में आंसर चाहिए
एग्जांपल सब कुछ यहां पर पढ़ सकते हैं
कुछ भी कर शक्ति है ना वर्जन निकालना
से कुछ एक्स्ट्रा तरीके
हीरापुर यहां पर
9.9.5 समथिंग
बेस्ट ऑन इट्स डिस्क्रिप्शन
करनी पड़ेगी नाम कॉपी कर लेते हैं इसका
इसको पहले पूरा क्लियर कर देते हैं
की एल्गोरिथम सॉरी
[संगीत]
यहां पे मिल जाएंगे अवेलेबल नेट बटन करने
के लिए कुछ लोगों की बनाई हुई और ध्यान
रखना है
सिस्टम पे ठीक है तो फ्रस्ट्रेटेड
होता है चलिए
बहुत दिखाने की जरूर है या नहीं दूसरी
तरीके होते हैं नॉर्मल तरीका होता है ठीक
है और एक स्त्री में थोड़ी यहां पर दिया
हुआ है उसका जो बता दूंगा आपको नॉर्मल
मतलब सिंपल जैसा आउटपुट है वैसा ही हो
जाएगा ठीक है आपका सिंपल आईफोन
कैपिटल
किया हुआ है
इस नॉर्मल आउटपुट का गैप किया है पुरी
इनफॉरमेशन
आपको पता है जेसन की तरह एक तरीके से समझ
सकते हैं और जो मतलब आ मतलब पर्सनल फॉर्म
में डाटा को से करने के लिए ठीक है ये
आपको अलग-अलग लैंग्वेज उसे करना है अगर
अपनी डाटा को तब यहां पर उसको एचटीएमएल
में आपको कर सकते हैं ताकि आप काफी साड़ी
चीज उसे कर सकें और स्ट्रिक्टली इसके लिए
आपको यहां पर आस देना है ठीक है
इसमें आपका थोड़ा ये जैसे मतलब कर दे रहा
है ठीक है और आपका चैलेंज दिखा रहा है तो
मतलब नहीं है उसका ये तो बेकार चीज है
ठीक है इसको हम लोग देखेंगे
यहां पर कॉपी कीजिए और पेस कीजिए ये हमें
फाइल दे रहा है ठीक है इसमें फाइल में मिल
जाए सॉरी
यहां पर कॉपी कर लीजिए
पेस कर दीजिए
डाउनलोड
फाइल आएगी
स हमने खोजना है की इसमें खोजना है
ठीक है
समरी देख लेते हैं
अगर रखना चाहें तो सारे रूम का ठीक है
खत्म करते हैं इसको भी
शेर कीजिए हमें टैग कीजिए फिर मैं अकाउंट
नहीं है आपके रूम नहीं कर का रहे हैं कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है हमारे साथ किया आपने उसका
सर टास्क का स्क्रीनशॉट मतलब दिखाना चाहिए
स्क्रीनशॉट लेकर ठीक है पर मैं ट्रैक्टर
के बताइए यार की आप कर रहे हैं सर ठीक है
उसे आपके लिए मेरे लिए भी फायदा रहेगा ना
समझ में आएगा दिक्कत तो नहीं हो रही है
दिक्कत हो रही तो दिक्कत ही बताइए प्लीज
पार्ट पे दिक्कत है सर मैंने दिक्कत हो
रही है कुछ भी बात है बताइए इस चीज को ठीक
है चलिए तो आज लेक्चर को यही पेंट करते
हैं हमारे एप्लीकेशन या फिर हम कर दीजिएगा
ठीक है उसे टाइम वीडियो आज की पोस्ट भी
नहीं उसे टाइम लेट पोस्ट रही हूं पर जल्दी
रिलीज हुआ है ठीक है तो उसमें हम कीजिएगा
देखिए इसमें जो लेटेस्ट मिलती जाएंगे ठीक
है चलिए आज के लेक्चर को इंटर करते हैं
नेक्स्ट लेक्चर